there are two battles going on between
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard the one
inside the courtroom and the one in the
court of public opinion welcome to
Entertainment Tonight Michelle Turner
has the night off more fireworks on day
22 as Amber rested her case but clearly
there's no rest for Johnny's fan base
Connie rolled into court today in a
black Escalade blasting Bob Marley
[Music]
and stopping to Rally his Rowdy fans
I hear it might rain those same fans
taunted Amber as she arrived in a pickup
truck
despite that legal analyst Julie
rendelman says the drawn out legal drama
could backfire for both sides it is
absolutely possible that both never
heard and Johnny Depp could receive zero
at the end of the day the jury by the
way can even decide that one or the
other defamed each other but they're
still not entitled to damages No One
Believes that Johnny Depp is here
because he wants to make money he wants
his name clear in court the focus was on
Amber's role in Aquaman 2. it was
radically reduced from what it was in
the script and what she even trained for
Amber claims her screen time was
minimized because of an alleged smear
campaign by Johnny Jason Momoa the star
he wanted her in the movie The Head of
DC films who was called by Johnny's team
testified Amber's role was actually cut
because she lacked chemistry with star
Jason Momoa remember conversations about
potentially recasting not bad at all at
the end of the day I think if you watch
the movie they look like they had great
chemistry but I just know that through
the course of the post-production that
it took a lot of effort to get there
Arthur Johnny's team is expected to call
Kate Moss to the stand tomorrow they
dated for three year years in the mid
90s if she testifies that he was never
violent never physical with her in any
way then that can cause a problem again
for a jury's view of whether or not
Amber heard's version of events is in
fact truthful
[Music]